انا لحتى الان من بعد شهرين انا كنت بتوقع
لما افلت الحروق انه الاقي جسمي رجع زي
اول تشفت انه لسه بده شي كثير لانه يرجع
مثل الاول او حاس انه مش حيرجع اصلا انا
اصابع هدول ما
بحركهم من سد الاوطار لسه في عندي رقع
يصير في جسمي هنا كله الوجع اللي بتعرض له
وجع مش طبيعي اصلا العدو الصمون سهت في
بيته ادى الى كسر
و في ساق اليمنى وفي اليسرى كمان اللي
قدروا عليه انهم عملوا لي عمليات ولكن ما
عملتش اللازم صارت بدها شغل كثير ولسه
بقولوا لي بدهم يشيلوه ويركبوا كمان جب
لانه لسه ما عمل العظم م لحن
خالص زياد عكاشه
اصوت 31
10 نزل علينا الصواريخ وبتر الجريه
وادي وبلاتين في ايدي و عندي كسرين
وتشوهات في جسمي بقدرش
اتحرك الحرك تشوه اللي بنواجهها هي في كل
انحاء الجسم بدءا من الوجه ومرات كثيره
هناك فقد في جزء كبير من عظام الوجه مع
حالات تسبب تشوه على المدى البعيد وفقد في
الاعصاب حتى هذه الحالات في الوضع الطبيعي
يراها اكبر مراكز الاصابات في العالم في
كم حاله في كل الشهر احنا اليوم نرى عدد
كبير جدا من الحالات هي تحتاج الى ادوات
خاصه تحتاج الى امكانيات وساعات عمل طويله
جدا انه بنتي اول مره اجتني بعد شهر ونص
خافت مني خافت من ايدي الملفين من شكل
ايدي بكون بدي امسك ايدها بهذ الايد
بترضاش قلي لا هادي ان هي خايفه اصلا
تمسكها وما بقدرش اقوم وعد الحالي يعني زي
ما انتم شايفين مع الحاله النفسيه زي
الذبت طبعا فيش علاج يعني مش عارف اوصف لك
يعني مسجلين لنا خروج من المستشفى واحنا
بنطالب يعني ابسط الامور الواحد يعني يطلع
يتعالج ح يركب اطراف مرضى الحروق هما من
اكثر الناس اللي يعانوا في هذه المشكله
مريض الحروق يجب ان وضعه وضعه في وضعيات
معينه لعدم لعدم وصولنا الى تقلصات في
الجلد فمثلا نحاول وضع اليد في هي الطريقه
حتى لا يحصل تقلصات علاج طبيعي يجب
ممارسته بانتظام مع هؤلاء المرضى يحتاجوا
الى علاج للندب بعد العمليات للاسف هؤلاء
المرضى لاربع اشهر الاخير لم يتلقوا اي من
هذه
العلاجات نحتاج له شغل كثير ارجع اني
لبيتي ولاولادي بنفسيه
احسن لاني انا مسيبا
ش نفس
ارح حت خجلانه
منفو
هذا نفسيتي وخايفه اس
نفسيته بحول ان اشتري جان تكون اكبر عشان
تغطي هذا اللي في
رجليه لكن مش قادره
البس من البلاتين حتى بضحك الورس معكل
يحصل امسى بدك تجي عل انا قلتله حاجه علي
انا انا حك وس كنت اجيب لان انا بروش
المسلوخ
كنت